i got two wallets in here and i got
singles like a bunch of ones
what's the reason that you got a bunch
of ones in there yaddy i don't know
i think this just changed from like a
broken hundred or something i wasn't at
the strip club that's what you wanted me
to say
yo what's up gq i'm lil yachty and these
are my essentials
[Music]
pot of gold no i'm just kidding this is
my grill
basically i have my grill in pieces
because i like it to give that permanent
look
you know like i like it to look like
it's permanent it comes in
six pieces because i love
bright smile the logic i come up in my
head is
i want to make a really lot of money
young or you know mid
age to like 35 you know so by the time
i'm like
48.50 i can do all the
that i couldn't do when i was younger
because i wanted to make smarter
decisions like
i haven't gotten any face tats or like
permanent teeth because like i want to
act
and you know i enjoy being a face for
you know big companies and it's
important to keep a proper image
so i'll say when i get like 50 i'll be
like
super rich i'm gonna get face tats i'm
gonna get
permanent teeth when i'm like 55 like
60 i'm gonna get like a boat right here
under my eye
like people think when you get old you
can't live but in my brain i'm like i'm
working super hard young so i get old
oh my god i'm gonna live an extravagant
life i'm gonna
tour the world on your eyes with young
bad [ __ ]
with diamond teeth and face tests at
63. and i'm gonna go by grandpa bo
grandpa boat with all the [ __ ] yeah
all right sunglasses
these ones in particular because these
are [ __ ] you know these are blue
tom but they're from the negro virgil
collection these are extremely rare and
they look like just their mommy
looks like some la gangsta 90s easy
nwa looks like a real sleek cool
vibe and just look fire i passed so many
over the years i've lost a bunch but
sunglasses was a real thing i really
like to collect sunglasses
i have a bunch of really cool vintage
chanel glasses
a few product glasses but also i have
this
collection of future mood glasses that
are super sick
and it kind of needs crazy because i
wish i had them downstairs
but i'm also doing my online with them
i'm super excited to just
really create and go outlandish with it
so
that's the one we're going to take to
the top look it up if you haven't heard
of future news studios
and glasses are literally insane
all right vitamin e make sure i take
every single day
literally everywhere i go no matter
where i am you gotta have vitamin e
thing with me is i don't eat anything
like i don't eat any fruits i don't eat
any vegetables
i don't drink orange juice my doctor
just told me that i need
vitamin e
[Music]
water not just any water just water
of course i've known of just water for a
few years now but it wasn't up until
maybe like a few months ago
i don't know it was extra hot outside or
i just had a cold
just water that just hit different to
the point where it was like
wow just water is literally the best
water i've ever tasted and it's
not this isn't an ad like jaden isn't
paying me this is generally just the
best one i've ever tasted so now it's
like
like if you saw my fridge it's nothing
but just water and i've just been trying
to drink a lot more water like
my skin gets very dry i think water
tastes better in the car
than in plastic i don't know if that's
true but i do i feel like it does so
just water is generally
can't live without just water literally
have to drink it every day i was
definitely drinking a lot of soda before
too much soda but i started realizing
like i started getting cotton mouth and
i started having acid reflexes like
middle of the night like i'd be asleep
and i'd wake up with like built up acid
in my throat in the middle of the night
and started scaring me you know so i
started cutting back on drinking sodas
i think i took all sodas out of my
refrigerator just trying to better
myself
if i don't then i won't be able to live
out the dream of grandpa both
[ __ ] at 64 in spain
[Music]
girl scout cookies thin mints i'm their
estimated underrated terribly duplicated
my dad introduced me to girl scout
cookies when i was maybe four years old
that's the only cookie ate therefore is
the only cookie and i grew up eating so
i've never actually tried another girl's
brow cookie to this day
i don't even know the other flavors i
don't even know thin mint is the one
the winner the green box don't give me
the baby blue don't give me the purple
i'm giving the yellow
give me the green the cookies are topped
tier
unfoldable i don't even like mint mint
chocolate i'm liking that but thin mints
are god's snack
i actually have my own personal girl
scout shout out to jada
jada always gave me right every time
it's that season they hit me up and it's
time to get some girl scout supreme
shouts out to jay to get me right with
10 minutes
try to get about 20 30 boxes gotta have
to miss that's also my favorite just
water and thin mints going crazy my
headphones
these particular ones are my faves
edition beats
shouts out to all my boys and phases you
know i am a phase clan member
these get me through any trip any flight
i love music music is my life again
another thing my dad introduced me to
i incorporated every piece of my being i
genuinely in the house have a
ton of headphones i mean speakers like i
speakers everywhere in my house
so i'm more speaker guy in my house but
on the road anywhere else
headphones any flight any hotel gotta
have great headphones
i love the red tiger stripe camera so
headphones are
a necessity
[Music]
pizza i love red bearing but not red
brands specifically just
pizza in general all right another thing
my dad introduced me to because my dad
is really
[ __ ] awesome definitely dedicating
this episode to my dad obviously
pizza man it's my favorite food i eat it
every single day i have been eating
every single day for at least the last
18 years
i'm 23 you know slowly since i was five
i eat it all frozen pizza new york pizza
brick oven thin crust not a step crust
fan i don't like chicago style either
i like deep dish but i don't like
original chicago style which is salsa
top cheese in the bottom that's
weird it's like lasagna i don't know i
don't get it i'm actually about to
release a frozen pizza
in grocery stores and that's the first
time i actually ever said that
that was new information that you guys
know now but i am working on my own
frozen pizza line
can't wait to release it because it's my
favorite of all time pepperoni is my
favorite but of course we have to cater
to everyone so of course you know we
gotta do four cheeses
pepperoni sausage uh supreme meat lovers
i do vegan pizzas for the vegan people
out there what we're not gonna do is
talk
about the competitors because we love
them all love our brand i love these
journals we love tonys i love
all of them i love the kroger brand
shout out to all the frozen pizza
companies out there
killing it doing your thing so that's
out the california pizza kitchen
and a frozen pizza lime i can talk about
pizza for hours bro pizza is my
my keys i actually suck with the keys i
lose them all the time
i am a terrible key person but keys are
a part of my everyday life
i actually don't have a key to any of my
houses and i have three
my mom keeps the spare up all my keys
for some fact if i
always lose them my lamborghini key went
missing for like three months
it was in my washing machine like in the
washing machine
in the little like circle part i don't
know how i got there he was hiding
in my car i literally sat in my driveway
for three months my lamborghini and it
was undrivable
of your cars which is your favorite my
main bag which is in the shop right now
my buck my back
precious hard drive all the data in the
world
all my music everything having to deal
with everything having to do with
anything that i've recorded
it's right there that's extremely
important i try to record music every
day so
that bad boy right there is everything
my engineer has a backup then my head
engineer
has a backup i don't have a backup i'm
[ __ ] if that's gone
spend more time with my engineer than
anybody
it's one time i engineered my girlfriend
i'm working on three projects right now
like a new york drill project where i'm
like flipping samples on drill beats i
just released a song called cortex on
youtube
i'm also working with production group
from philly called working on dying
it's that summer young term energy and
my fans are going to go crazy for it
that's really what they want and like
it's up there so
that was too super important i also got
a project with a little techa
it's damn it done and i'm gonna start my
album in third fourth quarter
i'm planning on doing all these side
projects because when i do the album
sounding album i want to be a completely
different vibe
all right my it's a miyaki shoulder bag
i'm a huge fan of simiaki it's got my
wallet
got deodorant i got diamond chain in
here
more sunglasses more and more sunglasses
like 50
sunglasses here gotta have all my
necessities gotta have your mask make
sure you always keep a mask
some hand sanitizer i got my earrings in
here
moisturizer for my face my passport
i'm cheating right now this is where i
added all my extra but this is a part of
my bare necessities man you gotta have
this i got two wallets in here
and i got singles like a bunch of ones
uh what's the reason that you got a
bunch of ones in there i don't know
i think this just changed from like a
broken hundred or something i wasn't at
the strip club that's what you wanted me
to say
no i think this has changed from 100
deal and this bag is really sick it's
really big but it's a shoulder bag
and i just think it's really dope and it
doesn't look flashy like it doesn't have
any labels or names just a black bag
with a leather handle
it doesn't look like anything's in it
it's just whatever
and those are my essentials thank you
guys for watching man